cappadocia and hagia sofia step aside
meet the newest top tourist destination
in turkey
the currency exchange office
i came to turkey from greece exchanged
100 euros here and bought gifts for
myself and the family i am very happy
i will buy clothes and food and whatever
we need for the children and
grandchildren for christmas bulgari is
much more expensive than here
eu shoppers hunt for the best deals amid
the turkish lira's struggle
as the national currency loses 35 of its
value over a year
they are shopping like crazy they don't
even know what they are buying they just
snap out five or ten of the same item
with the logic of selling it on or
thinking that they won't find these
again
they're really doing some serious
stocking up
for many christmas shopping is worth the
tiring cross-border trip
we set off by bus at three in the
morning crossed the border with our
group and came to the foreign exchange
office i exchanged 200 bulgarian lev was
1150 turkish lira which is very good for
us
when life gives you lemons
you can surely count on the neighbors to
prey on your misery